[Música]
los monde de indochina vivieron un
exilio forzado algunos hasta el otro
extremo del mundo esta tribu ubicada en
los confines de vietnam laos y china fue
cristianizada a finales del siglo 19 por
misioneros franceses algunos lucharon
junto a ellos en la guerra de indochina
en 1946 otros junto con los
estadounidenses durante la guerra de
vietnam por lo que cuando los comunistas
se tomaron el poder en la península en
1975 los hmong fueron considerados
traidores cientos de miles tuvieron que
huir y refugiarse en tailandia países
occidentales como francia y eeuu
acogieron a algunos de ellos el destino
de unos mil fue la guayana francesa al
sur del continente americano
el gobierno francés acababa de lanzar un
gran plan para desarrollar este inmenso
territorio y se consideró que los hmong
se adaptarían muy bien al clima difícil
del corazón de la selva amazónica todo
debía ser construido en un lugar que lo
único acogedor que tenía era el hombre
cacao hoy en día cerca de 40 años
después estos refugiados lograron
integrarse
pero qué papel juegan en la sociedad que
queda de escultura y de sus tradiciones
nuestros reporteros visitaron la guayana
francesa bienvenidos a boleto de vuelta
a cacao
[Música]
para encontrar a cacao hay que ingresar
a la selva amazónica recorrer un
centenar de kilómetros desde cayena a
través de la selva
hoy en día cacao se parte del paisaje
guayanés pero no hace mucho antes de la
llegada de los hmong exiliados de laos
aquí no había nada carreteras escuelas
viviendas los hmong construyeron todo en
40 años su trabajo dedicado y su dominio
de la cultura les permitió domar a la
selva organizarla cultivarla y volverse
los productores de frutas y verduras más
importantes de este departamento francés
del otro lado del mundo
como todos los días desde hace más de 40
años
josep se ocupa de sus cultivos llegó a
cacao siendo tan solo un niño sus padres
huyeron de la guerra dejando toda una
vida atrás
y aquí encontramos nuestra tierra la
guayana francesa como agricultor no se
puede pedir más aquí viví aquí estuve
aquí trabajé mi vida es la guayana y si
la guía
joseph creció entre el patio de la
escuela de las religiosas donde aprendió
francés y los campos donde ayudaba a sus
padres tuvieron que desmalezar la selva
a un árbol tras otro con las manos y
luego experimentar para saber qué
cultivar en el suelo arcilloso de la
guayana
si al principio el objetivo era cultivar
arroz luego cultivamos verduras y
árboles frutales empezamos a cultivar
desde ese momento con cómo se hace
tu sección
m
fue duro pero era nuestro oficio no
importa lo duro que sea el trabajo hay
que ir hacia adelante
dale ganado
como sus padres eran muy viejos para
trabajar en los campos
josep tomó el relevo e hizo fructificar
la parcela familiar
hoy en día posee varias decenas de
hectáreas y vende sus productos en los
mercados hasta cayena
a mis nietos les cuesta levantarse por
la mañana siempre toman tiempo para
alistar esta mañana es día de mercado un
cacao el primero tras largos meses de
cierre debido a la crisis sanitaria son
las cuatro de la mañana la madre de
joseph ya está de pie
[Música]
diane querida levántate tenemos que
alistar te necesito
los hmong viven y trabajan en familia
durante la semana los más jóvenes van a
la escuela durante las vacaciones y los
fines de semana ayudan a sus padres en
los campos y en el mercado las jornadas
son bastante completas
y si a cacao se hace estás aquí en cacao
esa es la hora que nos levantamos pero
si debemos ir a cayena es la una de la
mañana hay que ir por carretera para
poder vender a las cinco de la mañana
llegar allá la instalación es dos veces
a la semana así
diane es mi nieta él enseñó a tener un
buen ritmo de vida le doy ejemplo le
transmito los valores de los bonos somos
un pueblo de hombres libres y sencillos
somos trabajadores nos levantamos
temprano y nos ayudamos estas son las
tradiciones mont y es muy importante
para nuestra familia
los mon representan tan sólo el 2% de la
población guayanesa pero producen hoy en
día cerca del 70% de las necesidades en
frutas y verduras del departamento
comenzaron a vender su producción en los
mercados de guayaneses en medio de los
años 80 coles habichuelas rambután
pimientos los productos de origen
asiático encontraron rápidamente su
lugar en los stands
nos hacen vivir hacen vivir a la guayana
con sus plantaciones con sus verduras
son muy importantes para nosotros está
la sopa mont que es muy reconocida aquí
porque los montes tienen una manera de
preparar sopa que es muy particular se
vivieron
con el paso de los años cacao se volvió
uno de los principales sitios turísticos
del territorio y su mercado un lugar
ineludible a través de su agricultura
los hmong parecen haber logrado su
integración en el seno de una sociedad
guayanesa multiétnica
hola ya tiene este folleto hay que ir a
votar es importante
para la nueva generación nacida en la
guayana francesa la asimilación no debe
frenarse en las fronteras del mercado
clair decidió involucrarse en política
para las elecciones municipales a sus 30
años tras estudios de animación en
cayena ella que no soñaba con ser
agricultor decidió regresar a vivir aquí
[Música]
hace un momento que la población pide a
gente que esté motivada aquí no diré que
no soy conocida pero soy una joven
bastante dinámica y los jóvenes me
quieren entonces me dije que yo podría
ser el feeling entre la población y yo
en cacao la tasa de desempleo es baja
menos del 10% pero las oportunidades son
pocas casi la totalidad de los jóvenes
monk que viven ahí viven al ritmo de la
agricultura los otros son bomberos
profesores o se fueron durante los
últimos años claire ha visto a una buena
cantidad de sus amigos instalarse en
cayena o en francia continental la joven
mujer sabe que su pueblo y sus
perspectivas ya no corresponden a las
expectativas de la juventud moderna y
occidentalizada
y me gustaría que hubiese cosas que
pudieran hacerse aquí para nosotros los
jóvenes no me aburro pero eso les
permitiría a los jóvenes desarrollarse
de cierta forma y divertirse un poco
como todo el mundo
con tu marca
[Música]
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
[Risas]
hola todo bien tengo cita a las 330
desde hace unos 15 años van recorre el
planeta para reunirse con comunidades
mont exiliadas su padre combatió junto
con los franceses y los estadounidenses
el trata de combatir el olvido
quien conoce la historia de los monjes
esta tarde se dirige a una clase de
octavo grado en el colegio son paul de
cacao la cultura mont es una cultura
oral con la desaparición de los adultos
mayores
su historia se pierde poco a poco no
durante la guerra de indochina los hmong
combatieron junto con francia eligieron
francia y nuestros padres entregaron su
vida se sacrificaron por ustedes
es importante porque estas historias son
sobre nuestros abuelos nuestros padres
quienes dieron su vida es importante
decirles que dieron su vida durante esta
guerra
hay que transmitir el deber de memoria
es muy importante su sacrificio lo
amerita somos ciudadanos franceses como
todo el mundo tenemos nuestros derechos
y es importante porque somos hijos de la
república
bueno
en cacao una veintena de mont nunca
recibió la nacionalidad francesa
pensando ir si algún día algunos nunca
la pidieron otros simplemente lo
olvidaron
al principio no les vino la idea había
que sobrevivir ahora que están mejor
instalados y cuentan con mejores
condiciones de vida
desearían tener la nacionalidad francesa
porque hay un lazo con la fraternidad de
armas en indochina y también la cultura
francesa y así habla que yo foxes
van que necesita con un sin papeles
todo básico llegó a la guayana francesa
hace 43 años sin embargo sigue siendo
considerado como un refugiado por su
país de adopción todas sus solicitudes
han sido rechazadas hasta ahora el
motivo elevado por la perfectura siempre
es el mismo la falta de dominio de la
lengua francesa
tenía 30 años cuando llegue ya no estaba
en edad de ir a la escuela era necesario
trabajar de inmediato desde hace 10 años
y erradicados único solicitudes para
obtener la naturalización me convocaron
una vez a la prefectura para un examen
pero fue rechazado mi mujer y yo
quisiéramos ser franceses oficialmente
para poder por lo menos desplazarnos
libremente y sin miedo pecho
y no es normal que sigan siendo
refugiados deben obtener la nacionalidad
francesa para poder votar en las
presidenciales para alcaldes
en 2009 más de medio siglo después del
final de la guerra en indochina el
estado francés autorizó la instalación
de una placa en memoria de los hmong que
combatieron junto con las fuerzas
francesas modismo wason font es el
último combatiente de esta guerra aún
con vida en cacao a sus 100 años se
volvió uno de los pocos más en haber
sido condecorado con la legión de honor
y en combate durante cinco años con el
ejército francés espere mucho tiempo
este reconocimiento ya no creía en ello
después de tanto tiempo estoy orgulloso
de haber recibido esta legión de honor
cuando era joven no sabía que mi abuelo
había servido en el ejército francés
hacia mis 18 años me di cuenta de la
importancia de su historia
hoy en día estoy muy orgulloso de mi
abuelo antes de esto
qué es
[Música]
para josep y su familia es un gran día
celebran los espíritus de sus ancestros
un aire de tiene un órgano tradicional
acompaña al rito de las ofrendas
[Música]
otra de los huevos olvidaron los huevos
para el evento la familia compro un cebo
el animal será sacrificado para honrar
los espíritus y su carne compartida
entre todos
es para los ancestros para pedirles que
vengan a bendecir a la familia
los monos son animistas desde hace
siglos creen que cualquier cosa los
seres los objetos los alimentos poseen
un alma propia
estos rituales su mecánica y su
significado se transmiten mediante la
observación
la mayoría de las familias mont de la
guayana francesa se volcaron hacia otras
religiones a veces motivadas por
visionarios a veces por miedo a hacer
las cosas como no se debería en cacao
tan sólo el 10% conservó su tradición
animista
y es algo nuestro en el seno de la nueva
generación hay muy pocos jóvenes que lo
aprenden tampoco es bueno que se pierda
es algo que nos pertenece
y si se puede perder está ocurriendo si
nosotros los jóvenes no nos metemos en
ello desaparecerán
[Música]
esta noche yo sé y los suyos recordarán
nombres de ancestros hasta tarde
días después los esfuerzos de clair
pagaron finalmente su lista se impuso en
primera vuelta de las elecciones
municipales
como ella en los próximos años los hmong
de cacao refugiados que se volvieron
indispensables para su tierra adoptiva
tendrán que encontrar un equilibrio
entre tradiciones y modernidad para
salvaguardar su historia y su identidad
[Música]
hasta aquí el boleto de vuelta a kaká o
si quiere ver de nuevo este reportaje lo
invitamos a visitar france24 puntocom
[Música]